hey guys it's me you know real bandit
stay tuned till after the video for not
a sponsored segment but a message from
me to you
for as beautiful of a game as twilight
princess was and yes that's a hill i'm
100 willing to die on it was lacking
some pretty obvious zelda-isms for
instance in ocarina of time we were
introduced to the legendary great deku
tree who's supposed to be one of
hyrule's watchful protector spirits the
tree even makes a reappearance in the
wind waker as do its fellow kokiri
children reincarnated as the airborne
koroks but in twilight princess both the
great deku tree itself and the kokiri
slash koroks are nowhere to be found
then there's the mysterious
disappearance of the gerudo tribe who
were a pretty darn big deal in ocarina
of time there's even the entire garrito
desert area in twilight princess
implying pretty heavily that they were
here at one point in time so what gives
are there any explanations for these
missing pieces of the land of hyrule
well friend let me tell you the zelda
universe is a mysterious one alright
filled with many questions and
unfortunately not quite as many answers
but in the midst of all the mystery and
apparent loose ends there is lore
bountious lore enough lore to enable us
to speculate and theorize about what
happened in between the zelda games that
could explain the differences between
their respective lands of hyrule and if
you're interested in the lore behind why
the gerudo aren't in twilight princess
check out my theory on it link in the
description below but that's not what
we're gonna focus on in this video
instead we're gonna talk about that
first bit i mentioned the disappearance
of the great deku tree and all its
inhabitants but let's start with what we
know link starts off in the game as a
humble villager from the village of
ordon he lives in a tree house that's
located right outside a dense forest
almost exactly like the link from
ocarina of time actually except for one
very telling detail the inhabitants of
this village aren't kokiri children
they're grown-ups well most of them
anyway but the one thing that's always
bugged me when i played the game for the
first time was the appearance of these
ordonians this might sound like a huge
nitpick but hear me out have you ever
noticed their ears specifically how
round they are listen any zelda fan
worth their salt knows that hylians have
pointed ears this is something that's
been true since the beginning and most
notably since the jump to 3d in ocarina
of time the only people who didn't have
pointed ears were the gerudo the women
in garuda valley and even king ganondorf
himself all sport nice normal looking
rounded ears while everyone else in the
game has pointed ones listen i know you
may be rolling your eyes right now but
trust me it's a big deal i even made a
video about ganondorf's ears i'm
pointing all this out no pun intended
because according to the aforementioned
games and even some lore we can read in
masterworks creating a champion ear
shape is indicative of the hylian race
meaning quite literally that in twilight
princess link is hylian but the
ordonians specifically are not now of
course the people of ordon aren't the
only characters in the game with not
pointy ears but that doesn't really
matter for this theory the only fact i
want to drive home here is that
ordonians are not hylians they're
another race entirely so this begs the
question what are they well i'll just go
ahead and spoil the ending of the theory
by saying i'm gonna try to prove to you
that they are in fact the kokiri from
ocarina of time so let me explain rewind
back to the events of ocarina of time at
the end of the game the new deku tree is
sprouting and growing and link has
defeated ganondorf and sealed them away
and all as well and good but that was
the adult timeline which leads directly
into the events of the wind waker and
specifically into the new great deku
tree and the evolutionary koroks when
link is sent back in time though at the
end of the game the child timeline is
created and in that timeline the great
deku tree dies and no sprout is formed
see in the adult timeline link ages
forward by seven years and then returns
to the lost woods in order to break the
curse on the forest temple only by doing
this is the deku tree sprout able to you
know sprout this is according to the
little guy's own words and is evidenced
by the fact that the sprout didn't
sprout for seven long years until link
defeated the forest temple but seven
years ago link never did this meaning
the new deku tree never came into
existence this explains per lore the
absence of a great deku tree in twilight
princess but what does this mean for the
kokiri of ocarina of time according to
the kokiri themselves the great deku
tree taught them that if any of them
were to ever leave the woods they would
die this however is a lie well kind of
see at the end of the game there are
clearly several if not all of the kokiri
children outside of the woods they're
shown to be partaking in the wild
par-tay being thrown in the wake of
ganondorf's demise this takes place in
the corral of lonlon ranch pretty darn
far away from the kokiri forest so
clearly when the kokiri leave the woods
in the words of satan ye shall not
surely die but does this mean that the
deku tree was lying to them i mean what
was the point just to spread some
fear-mongering amongst the little forest
children this is purely theoretical but
i personally believe that what the deku
tree meant by this is that if the kokiri
were to ever leave the kokiri forest no
they won't drop dead but they will be
leaving the protection and influence of
the deku tree seeing as he is the
protector of the forest meaning that
what he meant by if you leave the forest
is really if you leave me see the reason
why i quoted from the bible a few
moments ago was because i feel like
something similar is happening here as
i'm sure some of you know in the early
chapters of the book of genesis the
story goes that the immortal adam and
eve partook of a forbidden fruit which
god told them they'd die if they ever
ate however after they ate it they
didn't die rather they turned mortal
death was added to their life if you
will i can't help but feel that this is
what the deku tree meant by saying the
kokiri would die if they left him when
clearly they don't perhaps what he meant
is that if they left his protection
death would be added to their life they
would become mortal and in the child
timeline events following ocarina of
time the great deku tree is dead and
gone meaning his protection is dead and
gone and the kokiri themselves would
therefore quote unquote die and become
mortal and be devoid of a guardian
spirit now let's return to twilight
princess in this game the only thing we
have connecting the kokiri to the world
directly would be their blatantly
obvious symbol present in the forest
temple i mean it is obviously the kokiri
symbol and it's all over the place which
implies that the entire temple itself
was built and once inhabited by the
kokiri and you know what the temple
actually is a giant hollowed-out tree
now let me think when have we ever seen
a giant tree associated with the kokiri
before oh yeah that's right in wind
waker in ocarina of time and recently
breath of the wild where the kokiri
slash koroks are associated with the
great deku tree and it just so happens
that in this timeline the great deku
tree is dead hollowed out remember what
happens in ocarina of time when the deku
tree dies monsters begin to invade the
forest so what if the kokiri were forced
to move further into the woods to escape
the growing number of monsters what if
they took shelter within the husk of
their dead protector the deku tree and
transformed the inside of the tree into
what we now recognize as the forest
temple in twilight princess but as we
can see once the corruption of the
twilight started to invade hyrule prior
to the events of twilight princess the
forest temple itself started to become a
dangerous place and was subsequently
abandoned by the kokiri who then moved
once again to establish a new village
the village of aordan where they lived
on until the events of twilight princess
and if the kokiri really are the
ordonians this explains why there are
kokiri symbols in the forest temple and
why the villagers of ordon who are not
hylians live right outside pharaon woods
which get this was called the kokiri
forest in ocarina of time according to
the encyclopedia and why one of the
ordonian people is literally named fato
or fedo however you say that which is
notably the same name as a famous kokiri
individual who has popped up multiple
times in the series now there's a lot of
proof in favor of this theory but there
are a couple counterpoints which i'll
discuss briefly the first being that the
forest temple and twilight princess
doesn't look much like the deku tree
from ocarina of time and its location
doesn't exactly match up i see your
point and i raise you a neither does
death mountain or lake hylia or caruto
desert or zoro's domain or hyrule castle
listen i personally don't put too much
stock into trying to figure out why the
layout or appearance of the land of
hyrule seems to change so much from game
to game especially when you've got
twilight princess taking place
apparently only like 100 to 200 years
after ocarina of time according to
aonuma himself and i'm not a geologist
but i'm pretty sure that doesn't give
that much time for natural changes to
landscape especially not changes of the
scale there's just no way besides
extremely large leaps of speculation to
explain why zora's domain is now located
to the far north of hyrule castle or why
the temple of time is now located within
a forest or why the gerudo desert is now
on the other side of lake hylia when
before it was neighboring it and
connected by a river it's just as
important as figuring something out is
to admit when you can't figure something
out i mean after all we're just supposed
to accept that this volcano is the same
as this volcano and that this lake is
the same as this lake so i personally
don't mind believing that this large
tree in faron wood slash kokiri forest
surrounded by kokiri's symbolism is now
this large tree in feron wood slash
kokiri forest surrounded by kokiri
symbolism especially when it would
answer pretty much everything regarding
the mysterious disappearances of the
forest dwellers the second counterpoint
is that the kokiri evolved into the
monkeys present around the forest temple
and not the ordonians themselves now
clearly i agree that the kokiri evolved
since that's the one thing they're shown
to always do in other games but i think
their evolution was into regular mortal
people complete with regular mortal
rounded ears i won't deny though that
it's possible that the kokiri did evolve
into the monkeys i mean hell maybe even
mido evolved into ook the baboon but i
just find it hard to believe that they'd
evolve into a form that can't speak as
that's never been the case in any of the
other games that they're present in i
also feel that the kokiri's special
forms are given to them by way of the
power of the deku tree and that without
the deku tree they'd turn into a regular
non-magical form which would in this
case be the non-magical ordinary
ordonian humans although this could also
be said about turning into ordinary
non-magical monkeys that much i can't
refute fully so i'll admit it is
possible that they evolved into the
monkeys but this is all just my theory
what do you guys think did the kokiri
evolve into the ordonians of twilight
princess did they turn into the monkeys
or are they all actually dead and gone
and this is just a random forest and
that is just a random tree and that's
just a random symbol let me know in the
comments below thank you so much for
watching please consider leaving a like
if you enjoyed the theory or at least my
efforts into it and subscribe if you
haven't already for many more super cool
lore videos to come hey guys it's me
again you know real bandit i just wanted
to pop in real quick and talk about
something rather tragic that happened to
me recently i was hacked
personally as in my personal facebook
account was hacked into an insta band
because that's how meta customer service
works they claim that it's so bad
because of covet era but apparently it's
always been terrible so i don't really
know just pro tip make sure you don't
have anything on your social media
networks that isn't backed up somewhere
safe that you have access to or else you
never know you might get instaband and
then immediately lose access to all
sorts of stuff i personally lost
pictures and videos of when my parents
were back together of some of my
grandparents that have moved on of my
own graduation my little brother's
graduation the list goes on but i'm
bringing it up here not just to warn you
guys about the dangers of keeping things
online without backing them up but also
because my youtuber instagram account
you know my instagram account under
bandit games was attached to my personal
facebook account and it got deleted too
so i'm essentially just trying to pop up
here and inform those of you who were
following me or if you'd like to follow
me for all the fun stupid stuff that i
post there that i have a new instagram
that's now under the name jordan
herndon96 which is just my real name but
don't worry i have it under a much more
safe gmail account this time i made a
post about it actually a few days ago
here on the channel and a lot of people
thought that the post itself was
suspicious which
is just so ironic and funny the more
that you think about it but good on you
people for being cautious and i'm
looking at you
ken rohr and my online id i assure you
it is i
the real bandit
unless i'm a robot under the skin i
probably sounded off because i was i
don't know
frustrated
flustered feeling hopeless if you've
ever had something stolen from you that
is priceless you probably understand the
feeling anyway that's the end of my
ramble but here's the recap for you
number one follow me on instagram
jordanherndo96 and number two don't
upload anything
anything on the internet that's
important to you without backing it up
first
that's all this is bandit hoping forward
this is bandit looking forward to seeing
you next time and signing out peace
[Music]
[Music]